[Music]
hello and welcome to every damn day hey
Internet what is the greatest animal
catching video of all time a new
contender has entered the ring watch
this this comes to us from the San
bernandino
the Sheriff's Department where they are
luring a pig with a bag of Doritos hey I
guess that pigs got the munchies right
guys show that next photo this is from
their Instagram my favorite part of this
story is that they said when they got
the call about the giant pig loose
they're like say no more we know where
it is because they've gotten calls about
this pig before and then one last photo
it's got a happy ending oh look at that
they got the pig and they got him back
safely inside his game I do I love a
nice animal catching video but a lot of
them do always have that hint of and
then they were out of that guy's
personal Zoo in Ohio do you remember
this mm-hmm
Janesville Ohio they've killed all the
animals very sad yeah it was really sad
I don't really want to get too into it
because it's very upsetting he brought
it up dude the animals know but like
what was your favorite animal one of my
favorite parts was they kept describing
the the pig was the size of a mini horse
a donkey this gives you no context to
how big the pig is it's a normal sized
Pig nobody just knows how big pigs are a
horse you could ride that pig huge yeah
it's true we have a zoo right now I have
your personal
pigs are nasty pigs will eat your finger
there's female pigs have supposedly
30-minute long orgasms CNN you can't
fully say for sure but it seems like
that's the kind of story that gets my
dad upset with science like you know
science is very good for a lot of things
this is how people are watching our show
now and like we learn about the climate
through science and all this kind of
stuff every piece of technology science
is in there but then also science
studies weird things like how long do
pigs orgasm and like that was a science
experiment or if a farmer was like damn
she's still going
harvest now also your pigs horny as hell
have you heard about that research study
from the 70s about the woman who lived
with a dolphin and they had like a
sexual relationship with the dolphin
yeah wasn't that what that movie was
based off of I don't know there's a
podcast about it but probably the one
that won the Oscar wait splash oh no
fished out of water
you know I actually love that they tag
Doritos in the pose it seems like the
San Bernardino County Police are like
kind of gunnin for a sponsorship if
Doritos you sponsor the show
I'll eat for full family size bags of
Doritos each episode was the Doritos was
just in the sheriff's lunchbox it was
like she had some Doritos for life and I
love this it was in a little plastic bag
so she has a bag of Doritos she's like
don't need the whole thing like seven
Doritos that'll be a nice treat
something you could probably learn most
criminals out with a good thing a Dorito
I think trail of Doritos is actually how
they caught Harvey whines I started this
episode by asking what is the greatest
animal catch video of all time it's one
of my favorite subjects and video on the
Internet it always brings a smile to my
face
so I've got a few contenders tell me if
you think this one unseats any of them
for the throne Jillian let's start up
one of my all-time favorite play that
video this is known as cute little puppy
gets onto a field of a soccer game there
are dozens of these on YouTube and
they're all wonderful this is from the
AP news and you can see he just wants a
belly rub but also he might be a rabid
dog you can tell the goalkeepers a
little afraid that's how bored goalies
are
I feel like pig eating Doritos is a
little higher on my list than this one I
don't know you love this video it's
reference in Nate's book different
believe is revolved not quite a genius
the Bible about the Bible all right I've
got something else let's see if I can
convince you guys
Gillian play this this one might be
better now this is a famous one this was
a famous day in internet history as you
can see there's two llamas there this
came to us on the same day that the
dress broke the internet when everyone's
like is it blue and black is it golden
yellow oh man this was also happening on
the internet I love so much so does this
one better
yes it's faster they cover more ground
they're not being lured into be taken
home to be chopped up and you're
probably not gonna eat these llamas it's
their very maternal creatures and so a
lot of farmers and stuff and like in my
hometown of Missouri they will have a
llama
on their farm to like ward off predators
because the llama will just like adopt
whatever like the cows or the Sheep or
whatever the llamas like well I'm their
mom now and they will chase away wolves
and coyotes and all kinds of
[Music]
piggybacking off of that have 45 minute
orgasms okay I've got one more video for
you this is I think my favorite animal
catching video this comes to us from the
third season a beauty and the geek press
play so you know that that means it's
time for the Sheep catch challenge and
beauty that was my partner which beauty
was it your wife doesn't watch the show
do you like that animal I like how
uncomfortable you got when we started to
ask you pointed questions about your
experience on a reality you know what I
realized that I think you shouldn't wear
a cowboy hat full-time full-time dude
I'd love to wear a cowboy hat all the
time but then I'd have to like change
everything about me I feel like yeah
it's like what is this your what am I
thinking of whatever you baby steps this
is your gateway hat I also I think
you've upgraded your glass as well wait
a minute yeah it doesn't look like you
named in the blonde hair in pigtails
tourgasm for 45 minutes there we go
Natasha do you have a shadow
boy sure dude since you got it right I
want to hear something yes oh I do it
upside down okay
more box three wrote on a Friday after
Jordans suggested that we all live in a
house together his response was every
damn day house not the worst idea for a
Comedy Central show oh you know what
that is a ringing endorsement say what
the worst idea was for common central
show just joking we're gonna do
something different right now
hi I'm Ryan Beckett I'm joined by Sarah
Tiana you can wash her Comedy Central
half-hour special this Friday at 11:30
Sarah thanks for joining me thank you
for sitting up straight gonna play a
game called before or after where I give
you a subject which is gonna be a comedy
central moment okay and then you tell me
if it's before or after another pop
culture event before okay the first
subject is kyun peels east west college
bowl sketch did this happen before or
after Barack Obama winning his second
election he did win - uh-huh well it's
probably before because I feel like that
sketch was responsible for getting Obama
elected that's correct next subject
Steve Carell and Stephen Colbert in
even-steven on The Daily Show shut up
shut up shut up be dogs and ice cream
I'm Stephen and I'm Stephen and this was
even steven did this happen before or
after the release of the original
Jurassic Park I believe the original
Jurassic Park was in a prehistoric era
mm-hmm you're talking about the movie
I'm talking about the movie okay because
there's actual yeah not the Jurassic
period no we're talking about film and
television I'm gonna say before that's
correct
after Jurassic Park I mean I'm not even
trying it's almost like you have 50%
shot of getting it right our next
subject
Chappelle's Rick James episode James
what is the bad bangers side of the face
what did that happen before or after
Facebook was launched Facebook itself
the website the website Facebook there
was a time where it did not exist no I
know I know
I think I'm twice your age so I remember
I'm 67 years old my second phone Dave /
Neal Brennan who probably wrote that's
good I'm gonna say it was after Facebook
it was after just barely it was after oh
wow that was a good that was a tough one
I don't know how you pulled that out I
don't know either
I'm literally flipping on February 11th
Facebook was launched February 4th of
the year 2004 of the same year yep Wow
yeah I really tried to screw you there
man
Dave's old our last subject are you
ready yes I was ready three questions
ago pretty next clip comes from South
Park and it is from when Kenny does not
die in an episode the first time that
Kenny did not die in an episode Kenny
would you please go over and pull the
light cords out of the wall
careful now Kenny those are very very
dangerous
okay did this happen before or after
Justin Timberlake left and sink I'm just
now finding out that Justin Timberlake
left in sync so that's very
disappointing I did not want to hear
about that on the roof before that's
correct it was before it was season 1
episode 10 December 17th 1994 so what do
I get for what do you win you get this
season 4 of uncensored mind of Mencia
DVD it is route it's heavier cuz he's
fat and this one some would say the true
prize is getting to watch your half-hour
comedy central special this Friday at 11
it's 11:30 at 11:30 I'm so glad I came
here
[Music]
epiphany a moment when you suddenly
become conscious of something that is
very important it could be a standing
desk or sitting desk either way I gotta
clear my browser history
that wasn't epiphany in history okay so
that's it for every damn day but we also
have a new shell on Twitter
called extra damn day so you can head
over to the Comedy Central Twitter page
and watch that and what what are we
doing that show talk about what's
trending on Twitter twitter.com and you
know what's trending right now is I
tweeted something oh well it has 240
plus retweets like 17 hours ago so it's
pretty good it was I did like a parody
of the Kanye video who's such a ho for
the democratic process just registered
to vote I'm gonna report it for
copyright infringement
isn't that crazy and I bet you dressed
up like a like a water bottle and then
six days later he's in the Oval Office
no all right and that's just the type of
riveting commentary you can expect on
extra damn day go check it out see you
later
[Music]